hello everybody and welcome to my review
of the oculus rift dk2 with elite
dangerous so my previous review is just
of the oculus rift what I was thinking
of it and this review is more of oculus
rift plus elites dangerous so first of
all elite dangerous what is it it is a
space trading game it's a crowdfunded
game its massive in the Milky Way galaxy
you've got 400 billion star systems to
travel between us physics space and
relatively scientifically accurate all
that is pretty nice and the game is
pretty much made for the oculus rift or
at least made with the rift in mind so
you can play this game on a monitor I
have played it on my monitor a few times
especially in gamma 1 point 0 4 there
was a brief time when the oculus rift
was having some problems but I greatly
prefer to play it on the oculus rift so
one of the things that's great about the
rift is you can kind of see here is
normally in the game to view this screen
for example you would press 1 but with
the rift you just look over there in the
screen will up here and that's really
cool the other thing that makes it cool
is like for targeting so most of what i
do is bounty hunting and one of my quick
complaints is for to Bonnie Hunt what
you have to do is you have to scan the
ship and see if the ship is wanted if
you're a bounty hunter you can either
wait till you get interdicted which is
pulling it which is when someone pulls
you out of super cruise or you can
interdict someone who is wanted and
pulled them out of super cruise and what
I found is that you can scan someone in
super cruise find out their wanted you
interdict them and then you have to scan
them again the exact same scan to find
out that they're wanted that's really
stupid I wish that was not the case so
you interdict them you know they're
wanted but if you don't scan them again
and open fire you will get a bounty on
your head so the
no good so anyways here I was trying to
interdict somebody and I found myself
being interdicted so that was fun that
happens quite often actually because you
kind of have to line up and hold steady
while you're trying to catch someone
else and then someone else comes up
behind you and interdict you instead so
this guy's a little simple eagle and one
of the nice things to just like with
with targeting in general is in this
game in order to target somebody if
you're playing on the monitor is you
basically have to point your ships nose
at what you're going to try to target
whereas with the oculus rift you just
look at the target and then when your
dog fighting if the target say is above
you like that you can't really see him
until you point your ship at them right
because your hue can all your vision is
fixed forward whereas with the dk2 you
can actually look around and so for dog
fighting it makes all the difference for
anyone who's curious as well if you're
noticing that i'm using flight assist
off at some points i basically just use
that to you turn off flight assist and
you can if you turn off light assist you
kind of push your throttle up a bit and
you pull back on your stick you can do a
quick flip around and kind of catch
people off guard sometimes they don't
realize you've turned around and you're
now facing them and especially this
eagle I caught him off guard because I
was able to actually RAM him to death
there so generally if you drop another
ships shields and you still have shields
a ram is really effective means of
killing someone especially if your ship
is bigger than theirs but you do have to
be careful if you're fighting a ship
that is bigger than you and you you go
to RAM them chances are you are gonna
die so anyways uh the only other main
issue I would say with oculus rift plus
elite dangerous is the graphics quality
so the graphics are a bit grainy now
what you're looking at here is actually
the debugging window from oculus rift so
actually what i'm doing here is i'm
playing on the oculus rift and then
there's a debug window that is popped up
on one of my other monitors and on
recording from there it is a bit grainy
and I would actually go so far as to say
is the resolution that you're seeing on
the video right now is the resolution in
game actually it looks just about the
same so keep that in mind now when I'm
playing a lead dangerous I'm not really
noticing that the resolution is poor
it's actually still extremely immersive
and I thought I would notice it I kind
of like higher resolution games but if
the game is immersive enough the
resolution truly does not matter and the
oculus rift really helps for immersion
the only time I ever noticed that oh
yeah the graphics are the resolution is
grainy is when I'm trying to read text
so you might have seen some people
complaining about the text man I'm just
whooping on this clipper normally the
Imperial clipper is one of the hardest
ships in my opinion to fight in the game
and is not one of the most expensive
ships or anything like that but it is
just one of the most challenging ships
to fight but this guy he appeared to
have purely gimballed or turreted
weapons and actually it was quite easy
to fight him for that nineteen thousand
dollar bounty er see our bounty and so
that brings me to another point is I'm
using fixed weaponry initially I used
gimballed until I found myself fighting
my very first player who was using fixed
weaponry and he was using chef and
basically made me useless so most
players I think from what I've found as
well use either gimbal door curtain
weapons because killing NPCs with them
are really easy none of the NPC's throw
chef but if you're fighting someone with
gimbal door turreted weapons which
basically the turret can basically fire
everywhere gimbal is basic if you're
kind of sort of aiming in the right
direction it'll aim for you but with
fixed weapons they don't do that you
have to aim perfectly you know yourself
and I thought that would be really hard
but after a while you do get kind of
used to it but if all you're fighting is
NPCs sometimes you may want to use
gimballed weapons but gimbal weapons in
general are actually less powerful for
some reason the class and the actual ray
getting aside fixed weapons do far more
damage so if you can get good at them
you definitely want to use them so here
I'm fighting this anaconda which is in
theory the hardest or the biggest ship
in the games they take a while to get
knocked down and they have tons of hard
points but again just like I'm
explaining now if you have say chef I
basically my too hard points in the rear
they are shaft so I cycle between the
two of them because I kind of take a
while to let you reshef so I have two of
them because they're your utility mounts
so I don't really need anything else I
just shaft there in since I'm using
multi cannons here I don't really have a
problem with heat or anything like that
when I was using being lasers you would
you know you would have to give a lot of
your ships power to weaponry but you can
see that actually I you you lose very
little power to power your multi cannons
so I actually end up leaving pretty
balanced or i almost put everything into
engines with one bar in each of the
sides but anyway um I don't remember
what I was saying to get me on that bat
besides the fact that i'm using these
weapons in the shaft but anyways with
the Anaconda on the weapons in them they
have their weapons in the front which
obviously they can hit you with but then
they have a bunch of other hard points
that are not on the front of their ship
and it makes it pretty hard if you are
behind the Anaconda under it or just on
top to the rear it makes it pretty hard
for them to hit you unless they're using
gimballed or turreted weapons so if you
have shaft you basically make it useless
now the other thing you do have to watch
out for is ramming this anaconda you can
even see that the NPC's tried to ram you
have to be very careful because one ram
would lose all of my shields and he
might lose like 20 percent or something
but he would definitely kill me so
anyway yet with the game of elite
dangerous there's actually a lot of
complaints and I'm not sure how you can
complain too much but I guess I can
sympathize maybe so with elite dangerous
a lot of people are saying that there's
either you know too much to do or
there's too little to do
and the game is basically a really open
world kind of setup you got 400 billion
star systems that you can travel to
chances are in this game's lifetime
people won't travel to all four hundred
billion star systems even so what you
can do in this game boils down to you
know you can explore you can go mine for
like raw materials and metals you can
dogfight people so either you can be a
pirate and steal people's cargo and
stuff like that or you can be a bounty
hunter like I'm doing here and just find
people that are wanted or I'll just
basically allow yourself to be
interdicted um being that you can run
missions and it is a space trading game
so you can also do trading for a lot of
profits probably the most profitable
thing is trading but it is quite boring
if you ask me so those are the main
things that you can do I might even be
leaving something out but if all you do
is say you want to earn credits it can
indeed be quite boring just running
goods to and from places and avoiding
interdictions so you don't lose your
entire bank um but I think if if you're
confused about whether or not you might
like the game I kind of liken it to the
open world of Grand Theft Auto so if
every one of these people that after the
campaign of Grand Theft Auto you are
bored and you go play another game then
elite dangerous may not be the game for
you there are seemingly unlimited
missions but they do get rather
repetitive so you would get bored I
think but if you're one of these people
that basically rushes through the
campaign of grand theft auto so you can
just play the open world at the end for
hours on end then elite dangerous is
definitely the game for you we're having
a staredown hear me and that anaconda if
he had just turned on his boosters he
probably would have rammed me to death
anyway but that's it that's a perfect
example of how annoying it is that I
have to scan him to find out he's wanted
interdict him and then I need to scan
him again why why frontier please fix
this so that's quite annoying the other
thing that is very annoying that I
we'll make a complaint about as if
frontier is watching this video but if i
get interdicted i think if you're
interdicting someone after you interdict
them you should have a like a very long
frame shift to drive cool down period so
too often I get interdicted and I found
out actually that in your coding their
frontier that if you just whoop up on
the enemy too fast they will there's
clearly something in the code that
basically says if you hit the hell out
of them right away to get out of there
and that's interesting code for sure
nice AI there but now I've learned that
actually you kind of have to I don't
know hustle hustle the NPC and act like
you're a buffoon for a while then you
get to take them down I think that's
kind of silly I'm / I think if you if
you interdict someone you should have a
very long frame shift drive cool down at
least one to two minutes but maybe even
more than that but too often I get
interdicted I scanned them I open fire
and then they charge their frameshift
drive and they're out of there and
that's very annoying because if they're
not in a little ship uh that's it um I
lose them and it's just a waste of my
time I just think if they're the ones
doing interdicting there should be a
serious cooldown period so anyways um
those are really my only serious
complaints with elite dangerous I would
still continue playing this game and I
definitely recommend this game
especially with the oculus rift but I do
have the caveats that if you're not
someone who who can figure out something
to do in an open world like if you're if
you are someone who likes to play a
campaign mode game and then you're done
this probably is not the game for you
but I would say the dog fighting is
extremely fun even though most of your
dog fighting is going to be against NPCs
it is very very fun I wish they had
combat zones back they were there in
beta but they're gone in gamma I really
want them back but that's okay I guess
we'll wait I appreciate the fact that
you can get up to a viper like I have
here with just a really a few hours of
work
and then you get a pretty basic Viper
and then you can upgrade the Viper over
time in have a lot of fun in the game
because as you can see this this Viper
is worth about a hundred and forty
thousand to buy from the shop this
specific Viper that I'm flying is worth
about 3 million credits after I've
upgraded a bunch but the ship I'm
fighting right now is probably I don't
know how many hardpoints he probably he
might have but this is a ship that's
worth like I think it's a hundred and
forty million credits i mean it's
expensive ship and so the fact that you
can get a pure combat ship for
relatively cheap and pretty much do
combat if you want that's very nice so I
appreciate that so you don't really have
to grind that much in this game but
anyway that's my review I think if
you're going to just trade or something
you don't really need the oculus rift
but the oculus rift is incredibly
immersive for the game the game is
really well made and clearly made with
the oculus rift in mind so I do highly
recommend it so anyways that's it that's
me rambling a bit for her the oculus
rift and the dk2 if you guys have any
questions or comments please feel free
to leave them in the section below
otherwise thanks for watching